I don't even remember this but you did
an interview with 60 minutes like 10
years ago yeah I remember really well
and at that point you had already won
three Super Bowls yeah and you said
though in that interview said there's
got to be more than this yeah I said
that in ten years ago when I think about
that I was pretty young you know and you
know I experienced a lot of success in
my career at a younger age you know it
was a lot thrown at me and I think I was
a bit overwhelmed with things you know
and there was a lot more in life to
accomplish getting married and having
kids have been an incredible joy in my
life I couldn't imagine a not being
married and being not having three you
know beautiful children and then
continuing to play sports and do what I
love to do I think over the last 10
years god there's been so much that's
happened in my life not just continuing
to play football but know I was in
living in Los Angeles for a little bit
now in New York and all the different
traveling experience that I've had
Asia in South America and Europe and you
know I lived in the Boston now we moved
out to you know Brookline so just been a
lot you know and I think about wow you
know I wonder what the next 10 years
will bring yeah but I do know I'm I love
learning you know and I love trying new
things and I love nooks you know
experimenting with things and you know I
think the best is yet to come you know I
still love playing football I said I
want to do that for a long time but I do
want to educate people on all the things
that I talked about in this book I feel
like you know I want to be that person
that can say look this is you know some
great information I want to share with
you and I want you to be able to you
know really benefit in your life too
because that would give me a you know
some great satisfaction